let us begin the speed run ladies and
gentlemen let us begin the speed run
and i'm going to play three minutes and
two seconds increment we've got a
500 for the first game
so we're gonna play e5 this is three
plus two three minutes and two seconds
knight f3 knight c6 everybody's familiar
with this line and he plays the scotch
game
now the scotch is one of the oldest
openings in existence the idea of the
scotch is to immediately contest the
center and to open up the bishop
obviously we need to respond to the
tension in the center the downside of
the scotch
is that he has moved the same piece
twice in the opening
why is that bad well part of the reason
that it's dangerous to do so is i can
develop my pieces
and simultaneously attack his pieces
while i'm doing that that is called
developing with tempo he takes my knight
now
xqc charlie against xqc played queen f6
which i'm gonna do here
this is charlie's move against xqc you
actually do not take the knight this is
called an in-between move
he plays f3 to defend i'm actually gonna
do five-minute games guys this is gonna
be too fast
now what is the downside of the move f3
what is the downside of the move f3
thank you for the 500 bits mid slam and
how should i take this knight
how should i take this knight now if
three weakens the king obviously
i actually will take it with the d-pawn
because you open the diagonal for the
bishop when you're considering
recaptures
one thing that you should always
consider how can i recapture
while also operating in a manner that is
conducive to my development now here's
the thing i'm going to develop my knight
here
he cannot castle that's why ben feingold
says never play f3
the move f3 essentially opens up the
diagonal and because i've developed my
bishop to c5
he's going to have a very hard time
castling why is that a bad thing and he
plays bishop f4
what is the problem in this move problem
with this move is he doesn't see my
queen
he only sees the fact that he's
attacking a pawn
and this will make me introduce the
concept of tunnel vision he blunders his
piece
the concept of tunnel vision is an
umbrella term
that i use to describe i would say a
majority of mistakes that are made
by players in the beginner level let's
say roughly 100 to a thousand
do i want to trade queens here
and this will make me talk about a very
very important concept which is
converting material advantages
that is going to be the theme of today
converting the theme of this game rather
converting
material advantages
converting material advantage thank you
sriracha for the sub
now i will talk after the game and i'm
writing down what i want to talk about
he goes f4
now whenever a pawn is moved remember
check
whether any pieces or pawns have been
left unprotected
because by definition moving upon leaves
weaknesses in its wake
obviously this leaves e4 unprotected or
b2 which fund is better to take
queen takes b2 very good because taking
the pawn on b2 when you see a good move
look for a better one
also attacks the rook on a1 he cannot
move this rook he's going to lose this
rook because
if he plays queen c3 to try to x-ray
defend the rook
notice that the queen and the king are
on the same diagonal big advice whenever
the queen
and the king are on the same diagonal
look for pins okay that happens so often
he just doesn't move the rook
he doesn't move the rook at all so i'm
going to take it now i'm uprooking a
piece and i'm attacking the knight and
guess what guys he's still not
he still cannot castle that is what
kills him he has to move his king out to
defend the knight
now here's the thing it's important now
to evacuate the queen i don't want the
queen to get trapped
on a1 so i'm just going to move it back
to e to e5 and i'm going to pin the
spawn to the king
i'm going to pin this bond to the king
why not bishop f2 check and take the
queen
um i'll talk about it and he resigns
okay so let's talk briefly about this
game
now the first mistake that he played now
queen f6 should make sense to everybody
i'm developing my queen and attacking
the fun threatening scholarship what
would have been the correct move the
correct move
would have been queen f3
the correct move would have been queen
f3 and according to theory
the move queen takes f3 this is an
endgame which has occurred
many many times thousands of times in
top level games i will also
do a little bit of trivia when we have
an opening i will tell you guys when the
opening was first played
and who first played it so i'm going to
use chess space to fill you guys in on
some historical information
the scotch whis first blade drum roll
please
the first time that the move d4 was ever
played and you guys are gonna have to
give me a second this
this really takes a very heavy to all my
computer
by napoleon napoleon but apart
was the first person actually according
to my search
who played the scotch against general
bertrand napoleon was a um
napoleon was actually an avid chess
player that has proven but
his actual games have been of disputed
veracity so people think that
napoleon's games may have been made up
five bucks for blind spot and five bucks
from shoe commander thank you so much
uh according to chess historian edward
winter he thinks that napoleon's games
may have been made up as a kind of
propaganda tool
to show everybody how good he is at
chess we'll talk about that later
why is it called the scotch because in
1824 the city of edinburgh
which is the largest city in scotland
the members of the city of the
chess club of edinburgh played a game
with the members of the chess club of
london
and actually played the scotch that's
why it's called the scotch and they
played it several times
um it was very common in the 19th
century to have chess games
between various cities um now
after e takes d4 knight takes d4 bishop
c5 knight takes c6 queen f6 the position
that you see on the board in front of
you
the move f3 has been played 117 times
um first played in 1993 but this is a
big mistake
the reason this is a big mistake as i
explained is that it opens up the
diagonal and in general i know this is a
very general piece of advice
but be very careful about pushing pawns
in front of your king
not only f3 but moves like g3 or h3 all
create weaknesses around your king that
needs to be treated with the highest
degree of caution
okay um and here i played d-take c6
which why am i doubling my pawns a lot
of you might look at this and say daniel
what the hell are you doing you're
ruining your pawn structure but
thank you the read grease for the sub
thank you guys so much for the support
it's important to recognize that in the
opening development is more important
than the pawn structure
okay you guys can write this down and
remember it development
is more important than small
deficiencies in the pawn structure like
double pawns
in general i think the pawn structures
are largely overrated part
they can incarnate another sub what
incredible support guys
so i could have taken with the queen and
preserved the health of my pawn
structure but
then my bishop would not be developed
and also after knight c3
let's say that i want to develop my
bishop play lady6 great
do you guys think this is a good move do
you guys think this is a good move
who can tell me why this is a good movie
because i am developing my bishop but
guess what following another piece of
advice i shared
the queen and the gang are on the same
diagonal boom shakalaka this wins the
queen
always watch for the queen and the king
on the same diagonal okay
so after dc i developed my knight to e7
i would have liked to develop it to e to
f6 but i can't
and the final two pieces of advice i
have before we transition to the next
game
i know that i'm spending a while on each
game but that's the point of the speed
run
a lot of people in this position will be
tempted by a particular move
could somebody tell me what move seems
very tempting here
what move seems like it actually could
be very very strong
yeah good job andro fb queen h4 check
checking the king now this seems
tempting because if the king moves this
is essentially checkmate
but what can white do hey fiery white
can actually block with a pawn
and so it's very very important not to
get overly tempted by checks
particularly when you don't have your
pieces developed
so many times i see beginners basically
looking at a check and delivering it
basically because it is a check
but remember the king moving away from a
check is not the only way to defend
against a check you can also
block a check with a pawn and that is
very commonly missed by
beginners actually by a lot of players
so that's why i developed the knight
he played bishop f4 and after this
things just went completely downhill for
him
now i think we had a question at some
moment about bishop f2 check was that
here
were people asking about bishop f2 check
here trying to distract the king from
the queen
well if that's the case remember
the knight is also defending the queen
so i can actually just take with the
king and if you take my queen the knight
also
so count all of the defenders of a
particular piece not only one of them
okay aquila asks why not queen d4 is a
threatened maid and the bishop at which
point aquila
at which point tequila here you can just
take the queen
here you can just take the queen so that
that is no good
last thing i'll share about this
position
how would i have played if i were white
here let's say you make this mistake are
you just busted
you're not busted there is things that y
can do silver turtle 14
and i will use this to introduce the
concept of a plan
now everybody has heard the word plan
before
plan is a sequence of steps that
you want to achieve to accomplish a
particular goal q42 holy smokes
people need to stop this is crazy crazy
amount of subs and support thank you
guys
now the thing with a plan is plans are
hard to generate
if you're a beginner because you don't
have a great grasp on strategies
and on pieces so it's hard to find one
move much less generate a sequence of
steps
but i do want to show you how i think
about planning
and we'll obviously talk a lot more
about that when i play more advanced
players thank you player jaguar for the
sub with twitch prime
what could a plan be in this position
what could a plan be in this vision
and when i asked what a plan could be
i'm asking about the final objective
what would be the final
objective of a good plan here for white
what does white want to achieve and you
guys do know what white wants to achieve
white wants to castle so there are two
possible plans one is to castle long and
in order to castle longwood you need to
do
you need to develop the knife the bishop
the queen and you can cast along that is
one plan
what would be the other planet fight
wanted to castle short what would he
need to accomplish as an intermediate
step
in order to castle short thank you
stefan jacobs for the sub
can why can't white castle uh short
he would have to get rid of the bishop
then i asked myself
how could i get rid of the bishop well i
would have to put my bishop on e3
captain call
the sub why can't i put my bishop on e3
cash flow real this is unbelievable
amount of subs right now thank you guys
so much
you can't play bishop e3 because the
square is undefended
okay so how do i prepare bishop e3 and
i'm sure anything i can't keep up with
this
you would have to play queen e2 okay
let's say the black castles
can you now finally play bishop e3 out
of court thank you for the sub
this is ridiculous thank you can you
finally play bishop e3 or do you need
one more preparatory move no you cannot
because the b2 pawn is hanging and
stefan gifting us up to code sensei
and wordable something is ridiculous
now what would you need to do then in
order to block the queen's access to b2
you would have to go either knight c3
or you would have to go c3 and then you
can finally go bishop e3
and prepare to castle so i know that
when you hear the word plan you might
think of some mythical
15 move idea but guess what guys
plans can actually be pretty simple and
i claim
that even a beginner can come up with a
plan if you know how to think logically
and you know how to essentially
you know how to ask the right kinds of
questions meat slim five subs to the
community crumbly cheesecake teddy teddy
bell jones wolfie 6925 and netsky thank
you so much
well ibrax asks isn't trading dark
squared bishop bad for white
it could be but it's very important to
have a set of priorities
the top priority for white is the castle
i know
here i don't care what's a good trade
and a bad trade as long as i can castle
because i would much rather not get
checkmated
thank you pawn m than care about good
trades and bad trades so i'll talk more
about priorities later
after he blunders the bishop the game is
basically over so takeaways from this
game
number one first and foremost very be
very careful about pawn moves in front
of your king
particularly the move f3 as ben feingold
reminds us
number two development is more important
than pawn structure especially in the
opening
number three in terms of planning you
ask yourself questions about what you
want to accomplish
and then you try to understand the
obstacles that stand in your way of
accomplishing it
obstacle number one is the bishop
obstacle number two is the fact that the
e3 square is not defended
obstacle number three is the fact that
the b2 pawn is now
not under control if we play bishop b3
solving all of the obstacles leads us to
a plan a plan leads us to accomplishing
an objective
any questions before we move on
okay i'm writing all of this down so i
can later maybe form a document
where i contain all of these advices now
let's continue with the next game
i want to i do want to keep things
moving smoothly so